the prime minister reopened ukraine's
canadian embassy sunday the flags flying
in cave is symbolic but it's real the
ukrainian canadian congress was glad to
see justin trudeau the deputy prime
minister and foreign affairs minister in
ukraine but not impressed it's taking
canada so long to bring ukrainians here
on chartered flights
it's been one month since the prime
minister promised to do just that along
with temporary hotel stays and income
support it's on the verge of an
unacceptable delay uh you know there's
planes flying out of warsaw berlin paris
rome every day concerns echoed by the
opposition the government was
inefficient with the afghan and we see
the same thing with the the ukrainians
it's a big failure from this government
uh
two
those people who wants to come here
and who already have their visa to come
here but they don't have the money to
get into a plane
i mean this is ridiculous conservatives
want that visa requirement waived and
chartered flights faster we want a
concrete plan we want a concrete
timeline from the minister i really
understand and i appreciate all those
people
who want things to move faster and we
want it to move faster
as well no flight timeline from the
transport minister who continues to
blame logistical challenges
we're coordinating where everyone is and
who wants to come and so so we can
facilitate
the departure points and landing points
somehow the province of newfoundland and
labrador was able to work through the
challenges the first government
chartered flight full of ukrainians
arrives in saint john's monday evening
we asked the federal transport minister
about the province's success but he did
not directly comment abigail beeman
global news ottawa